the big event was supposed to be
Saturday then it was pulled forward over
concern about far-right groups coming to
London this weekend
protesters rolled into town on bikes and
skateboards but reaching Hyde Park the
numbers were nothing on the scale of the
thousands last week the Prime Minister
and London's mayor asked people not to
protest because of the virus Boris
Johnson said the demonstrations had been
hijacked by extremists intent on
violence and said after it was
graffiti'd last week it was shameful
that the statue of Winston Churchill had
to be boarded up to protect it the
statue of of Winston Churchill who is a
national hero has had to be boarded up
for fear of violent attack and that to
me is both absurd and and we should look
sometimes at the positive stuff we've
got more young black and minority ethnic
kids going to university than ever
before more black kids doing the
toughest subjects in school doing better
than ever before looking at the
positives it's true the number of black
and ethnic minority students taking part
in further education has increased eight
percent in six years
but with school children this group
continues to have the highest temporary
exclusion rates and in business the
number of black and ethnic Directors in
the footsie 100 actually drops in 2019
we really are going backwards and the
people who are up there only about 15%
of them are English passport holders so
we are a net exporter of fame talent
while we're importing some of those
people in leadership positions in our
largest institution while this protest
was intent on being peaceful there are
still concerns about clashes at the
weekend we've certainly seen some people
who are talking about coming to London
for example to protect certain areas or
certain buildings that monuments and we
can anticipate that some of them
whatever their political persuasion our
intent some of them are intent on having
a confrontation with people from the
black lives matter
movement so my message is please just
stay away this weekend Winston Churchill
is not the only monument that's been
boarded up for protection there is a
concern that this focus on historic
figures and statues is detracting from
the more current message that the
protesters are trying to get across
everyone forgets the rule roots of evil
that we're dealing with right now we've
continued to deal with as a society and
as a black person which is institutional
racism today support the protest and
also make a change in the future
it's a political and policing challenge
the issues too important to stifle but
the risks of confrontation and violence
and the spread of the virus all too real
Jason Ferrell Sky News